to tackle the refugee crisis turkey made
some very interesting proposal proposal
concerned directly the border control
the cooperation between Greece and
Turkey and the proposals are linked to a
request of the Turkish side that those
people those refugees were are in Turkey
need support in the country and I'm not
speaking about those people who are in
the camps people who are in the country
around that need for their children
access to school need for the family
access to healthcare the further request
of the Turkish side for additional money
3 billion euros I in the debate I
discussion needs the cooperation with
the European Parliament we need an
additional budgetary procedure quite
clear that there is an attempt to link
the questions related to the refugee and
my great migration crisis with the
excess process but one thing is for us
as European parliamentarians clear we
have to separate the excess excess
negotiations between Turkey and the
European Union and all the question
related to opening of new chapters from
the short term management of the refugee
crisis
my